you have a twelve-year-old daughter is
that right I do yeah okay is what's she
into these days like can you relate to
her because I have a daughter that's
about the same age she just turned 13
are you able to like connect with her at
that age yeah yeah you know we'd do a
lot of stuff outside stuff and you know
go hiking or go horseback ride and you
know ride the ATVs or you know generally
the dangerous stuff she does with me and
oh you're a terrible father then yes
that's a dream what about music do you
like the the same music can you listen
to her music yeah I've learned a lot of
her music you know she's into like
Rihanna Taylor Swift I took her to see
Taylor Swift it was last year that was
kind of fun
yeah was the concert fun the concert was
fun yeah we went got to go backstage
Taylor was nice enough to let us come
backstage and she got to meet Taylor
Swift and I went backstage and Chris
Rock was there with his his two little
girls and so Taylor method call the
girls and then she said hey you know my
one of my videos the guy from my video
is here and he's the number one male
model in the world and I want to
introduce him on stage and I'd love it
if you and Chris came up on stage and I
could introduce you guys as the number
two and number three male models and go
Brooke so we we go uh Chris and I look I
had no idea was coming across I look at
each other and he hadn't shaved and we
no no not really ready to go on stage at
the Staples you just want to enjoy the
concert and suddenly you're being asked
but you don't have to do it yeah
whatever you need Taylor we're here to
help you know that so so next thing I
know underneath the stage you know the
stages have that little elevator hole
that shoots up sure that's how I come
out on stage every night yeah
so you know you know of course so we're
underneath and the other the model guy
he goes up first and walks down this
long catwalk and then Chris Rock and I
are there and I remember just stand
there looking at him like underneath the
stage and thinking well ha this is very
bizarre and I never worked with them
before I don't really know him that well
little buddy's a nice enough guy and we
both look at each other just kind of go
okay turn it up to 11 and act like a
fool yeah here we go and it was kind of
fun we walk down the stage and dance we
have a clip of this you guys rock it on
stage unannounced and act like models in
front of 11 year old girls let's take a
look at this
[Applause]
look at walking for me but the better
model in the world has ever done that no
I think Popeye that's how Popeye got
around but the funniest part is so the
next morning we're having breakfast you
know and just her and I watching
watching the news or my little pony or
whatever it was and one of the two yeah
that's how it goes yeah and I say so
your dad last night on stage with Taylor
Swift pretty cool what do you think and
she goes ah I thought your walk was
cheesy puts it all in perspective that
age they don't care yeah those dorks
they don't care doesn't matter what
you've done
you